Speaker 1: So it turns out that there's actually
a part two to the Fox News interview that
Donald Trump did with Sean HANNITY.
We looked at part one yesterday and we are
going to look at a little bit of part two
today.
This is a part of the interview that is significantly
more understated in tone, but it is significantly
scarier to many of you who have been emailing
me and saying, David, what exactly is Trump
talking about and is he really serious about
this stuff?
Also, of course, raising questions of Trump's
cognitive state, as is always the case.
Were they Freudian slips?
Were they brain glitches?
Well, we're going to figure that out.
The second part of the interview included
Donald Trump bizarrely claiming that he got
rid of Naito and built USMCA.
Now, Sean HANNITY helps Trump out.
And then, as you can see, Trump looks very
confused.
HANNITY helps Trump out and says, You mean
NAFTA, not NATO.
You got rid of naphtha and built USMCA.
But even that actually isn't really much to
write home about.
And I'll explain that in a moment.
Check out this bizarre moment where HANNITY
quite literally has to help Trump out of this
mess.
Speaker 3: So if I made a lot of great trade
deals or I changed a lot of those deals where
it was a bad deal for us, now it's a good
like us.
M.K.
With Naito, I got rid of Naito and the USMCA.
I made a great trade with China.
If our farmers are to this.
Speaker 1: Day, notice that.
HANNITY tried to sneak in NAFTA.
Trump just steamrolls it, made.
Speaker 3: Tremendous money because of the
deal, but because of COVID.
I don't even talk about that deal because
that override overrode everything, right?
Speaker 1: So completely insane.
What Donald Trump is talking about says he
got rid of Naito to replace it with USMCA.
Of course he didn't.
What he got did.
What he did was replace NAFTA with the USMCA.
A couple of interesting things here.
Number one, of course, to some degree, you
could say this is a Freudian slip.
Donald Trump was one of the most hostile tornado
American presidents.
And when he says, I got rid of Naito, he would
have liked to get rid of Naito.
To have gotten rid of Naito.
He didn't.
And instead, he just it's just a Freudian
slip.
The other aspect to this is that the continued
claim that replacing NAFTA with the USMCA
is some kind of major accomplishment.
It's basically NAFTA with marginally different
provisions about automobile manufacturing
with a new name.
And it is true that USMCA differs from NAFTA
in that it changes the requirements for vehicle
manufacturing.
What percentage of the parts versus the labor
needs to be done where.
But it is very similar to NAFTA.
And again, claiming it as some kind of big
legislative victory is very, very silly.
I almost thought that it was like doctored,
but it was just a Freudian slip, I guess.
Donald Trump also saying that if he's elected
here, you know how Trump does this thing where
he can't help himself.
He always has to make the promise more grandiose
and he has to make the claim more grandiose.
There were 5000 people at my rally.
There were tens of thousands.
And it's probably double that.
He just can't stick to reality.
He used to say he would fix the Russian invasion
of Ukraine on his first day as president.
Now he's saying he would fix it even before
taking office, which is, again, he's he always
has to go for it.
Speaker 3: Said I would fix that within 24
hours.
And if I win before I get into office, I will
have that war settled.
100% sure.
And everything.
I said.
Speaker 1: Yeah, of course that's not the
case.
It doesn't make any sense.
And Sean HANNITY really doing his best, You
know, the hand anything is interesting that
this two night special interview with Donald
Trump.
It does serve as evidence that at least overtly,
HANNITY is still on the Trump train.
We know that HANNITY was involved in the Fox
News text messages behind the scenes that
are part of the Dominion lawsuit.
He expressed concern about some of the things
that were being repeated.
He expressed concern about Sidney Powell and
so on and so forth.
But at least publicly, he seems to be very
glad to give Trump these total softball interviews,
allow Trump to lie, lie, lie and present no
pushback.
And so it's interesting in the context of
what is the next year going to look like if
indeed this is a heavily contested primary?
Right now, I don't call the Republican primary
contested in the sense that there are other
people running, but it's Nikki Haley and Vivek
Ramaswamy.
Neither has a shot.
DeSantis is polling pretty well, but he's
not actually running.
So if the Santos says I'm running and if his
polling doesn't continue declining, then we
will say, okay, now we've got a real primary
on our hands.
So far, I can't really say that that's the
case.
Trump's theory on Chinese politics is that
she is in charge because the smartest person
gets to the top.
And I sort of think Trump is trying to analogize
to himself here.
Trump sees himself as a very stable genius,
and he seems to be analogizing that also in
the United States, the smartest person gets
to the top, as evidenced by Trump having been
president for four years.
Speaker 3: The next thing I think a person
running for president, you could even say
running for certain offices if you want to
know the truth.
Now, I don't know if it's constitutional because
people would say it's unconstitutional, but
I would say that if you could do it.
But I'd like to see it for anybody running
for president.
I think somebody from running for president
and taking a cognitive test, you know, they
do it in China, but it's done in a different
way.
They have a caste system.
Speaker 1: Isn't that nice, guys?
The caste system of China will allow you to
figure out who is fit for duty and who is
smart.
I mean, it's it's not even sort of like, but
benevolent dictator stuff.
It's just straight up.
She is great.
China's caste system.
This is wild stuff.
Scary to the rest of the world.
Speaker 3: And the smartest person gets to
the top.
I'm glad it's part of the.
Speaker 2: Talk show and the media people
and people in the press.
Speaker 3: You've proven yourself at the highest
level you can.
Speaker 1: So Trump just gushing about the
intelligence of Xi as well as the caste system.
Genuinely horrifying stuff.
Lastly, Donald Trump tells HANNITY there wouldn't
have been any Chinese spy balloons under my
watch.
And of course, there were Chinese spy balloons
under Trump's watch.
Speaker 2: And what would you have done with
the balloon and what would you have done if
Putin took down one of your drones?
Speaker 3: The bomb wouldn't have done anything
with the balloon because it wouldn't have
happened under me.
Wouldn't have happened.
They wouldn't have sent the balloon.
If this is a big balloon, this is a balloon
where you can see it from.
It's like three 75,000 feet away.
People are looking very strange to see it
up there.
Speaker 2: We only found out because of a
guy, a man, Pat Montana.
Speaker 3: They wouldn't have done it.
I'm just telling you, just like Putin would
have never gone into Ukraine.
Speaker 1: So Trump says they wouldn't have
done it, except they did.
Now it is true.
Trump didn't find out about it until later.
That's absolutely true.
I'm not pretending Trump knew about the balloons
when he was president.
We have now learned that there were multiple
instances of Chinese spy balloons overflying
the United States while Trump was president.
Trump's claim understand is they wouldn't
have done it if I were president, but they
did it when you were president.
He wasn't told there was some kind of decision
made by I guess it was the Pentagon that it
didn't need to get to Trump, but they literally
did it while Trump was president.
And he wants you to believe they simply wouldn't
do it if he was president again.
Scary interview.
The romanticizing the continued romanticizing
of authoritarians and wannabe dictators and
seeing them as just smart and great.
And they've got this great system.
They don't have to deal with the press.
They just crush the press.
They don't have to deal with courts that might
indict them.
They just control the courts.
He loves dictator type scenarios because he
sees them as the easiest thing for him.
If he were to govern.
And he's not wrong, wasn't it George W Bush
who said it'd be much easier if it was a dictatorship?
Trump seems to really want that.